este es aserrín de pino y de ciprés
finamente cernido materia prima para la
realización de estas hermosas alfombras
con las cuales antigua guatemala
engalana sus pisos en esta semana santa
una tradición que para los católicos
representa la entrada gloriosa de jesús
a jerusalén pero que para los turistas
puede simplemente ser un espectáculo muy
colorido y me encuentro con uno de los
artistas más emblemáticos de estas
alfombras él es rolando ortiz don
rolando porque esta tradición es tan
importante para los antigüeños porque
antigua es la meca del catolicismo
centroamericano
aquí hay toda la agencia católica
prácticamente y se conmemora esto por
las procesiones que se hacen y
principalmente por la entrada triunfal
de jesús a jerusalén y es que justamente
hoy don rolando ha impartido un taller
para que sean los turistas los fieles
las personas curiosas que realicen esta
alfombra de manera colectiva y una de
ellas es us link garcía as link de qué
país vienen de honduras como le ha
parecido la experiencia la verdad un
taller muy dinámico bastante concurrido
se siente el fervor religioso que emana
de nuestro hermano centroamericano y son
costumbres que como centroamericanos
compartimos
fervor y arte efímero con el cual la
ciudad de antigua recibe a más de 500
mil personas en esta semana santa que
estuvo pausada por 2 años